on n'a pas tous les jours 20 ans le
centre artistique long de
Vélizy-Villacoublay fête son
anniversaire tout au long de l'année
2023 célébration d'une programmation
pluridisciplinaire orientée vers
l’écriture contemporaine théâtre danse
musique ou encore cirque son proposé
dans la structure de 17000 mètres carrés
c'est ce que le spectacle vivant produit
aujourd'hui et souvent dans ses
propositions il y a des gens
extraordinaires ils renouvelle les
genres et renouveler les gens c'est
aussi amener les gens vers la surprise
vers des émotions nouvelles pour ces 20
ans longues avec conviés la compagnie
Carabosse avec son installation de feu
sur le parvis une balade chaleureuse
dans le froid hivernal 500 torches
enflammés et fontaines incandescentes
étaient disposées autour du public ce
samedi 28 janvier le collectif
d'artistes parcourt le monde avec ses
installations depuis une trentaine
d'années moi depuis Gama j'adorais la
flamme et c'est quelque chose qui
rapproche qui rapproche les gens en fait
qui ont du feu on se sent bien et à tout
un truc de chaleur qui est quand même
hyper sympathique pour tout le monde des
rapprochement des gens je crois en fait
qui nous plaignent dans ce qu'on fait on
avait un peu l'impression d'être dans un
autre monde quand on marchait tout ça et
c'est super beau surtout là de base oui
voilà
sans vraiment s'arrêter quoi
très loin mais voilà on découvre une
nouvelle place et un mot bâtiment et
belle manifestation prochain rendez-vous
anniversaire pour long de le 10 juin
2023 le chorégraphe autrichien Willy
Dorner organisera une déambulation
autour de sculptures humaines dans les
rues de Vélizy-Villacoublay
[Musique]